vor kurzem hat mit von easy englisch ein
video gemacht dass mir so gefallen hat
dass ich es sofort kopieren möchte und
in diesem video ging es um ein
gedankenspiel und zwar stellt euch vor
ihr hättet ein abendessen und zu diesem
abendessen könntet ihr drei leute
einladen egal ob sie berühmt sind egal
ob sie noch leben oder schon tot sind
jeder würde kommen den ihr einladen und
das fragen wir heute die leute auf der
strasse wen würdest du einladen zu
deiner fantasie dinner party und warum
los geht's wer wäre dass drei
wunschkandidaten mit denen ich ein
abendessen verbringen wollen würde
kurt cobain
sie war ob maly also wenn ich mir drei
menschen essen gehen könnte während das
albert einstein frida kahlo und der
glücklichste mensch der welt
lenin stalin karl marx nein
ja dachte ich auch irgendwelche möchte
leute die sich gehabt haben
[Gelächter]
doch es gibt glaube ich jemand das will
karl liebknecht das wäre khaliq nicht
und dazu gibt es gundermann ich weiß
nicht ob sie den kennen das ist ein
liedermacher der ist schon tot
der ist hat er ist 1998 gestorben glaube
ich das ist ein liedermacher aus der ddr
gewesen der gleichzeitig baggerfahrer im
braunkohletagebau war und liedermacher
und bei der stasi war
neville gott hat pablo picasso und
empfinde ich jetzt gerade tolle tricks
und jesus quartal 33 göttliche personen
zu reden ist einmal str sie ist sie ist
psychotherapeut und meine lieblings
schriftstellerin dann die zweite person
wäre meine schwester weil es einfach
spaß macht
man darf drei personen einladen weiß
auch nicht ich werde einen laden zum
abendessen walter gropius den
architekten der wirklich einladen weil
ich das spannend finde wie er sich das
vorgestellt hat damals in den sechzigern
50ern und noch früher wohnraum ganz viel
wohnraum zu schaffen für menschen
ich würde willy brandt einladen weil ich
glaube dass der in den 70ern viel für
umbruch in deutschland stand und mit dem
gerne einladen und die wäre das so
gemacht hat und ich würde gern sprechen
mit barack obama der weder dritter an
unserem tisch der hätte bestimmt auch
spannendes zu erzählen und seine sicht
auf die dinge in den usa aktuell meine
oma dies leider schon verstorben und
meine mama die grund im ausland die
würde ich auch gerne einladen
also ich würd karl marx ja einfach aus
interesse wie er so gelebt hat seine
zeit seine erfahrung und dann hat er um
stein kann ist dem ich sehr gerne mag
auch aus dem 20 jahrhundert und
vielleicht aber nur aus witz angela
merkel einfach nur damit sie mal da ein
bisschen erfahrung sammelt vielleicht
das ist ein bisschen anpasst was lernen
kann
[Musik]
übrigens wenn ihr mit diesen videos noch
intensiver deutsch lernen möchtest dann
laden wir euch ein mitglied von easy
german zu werden
als mitglied zahlt er einen dollar pro
woche und bekommt dann zu diesen videos
transkripte vokabeln und interaktive
übungen worüber würdest du mir den
münchen bilden
na gut ich hab ja und zwei religiöse
menschen bei mir da müsste man
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen darüber
sprechen
man kann aber ist sicherlich mit denen
auch über musik sprechen da ist glaube
ich auch mit jesus sowieso ja vielleicht
vielleicht erzählt er dass es ein
paradox ist dass er mit bruder zusammen
am selben tisch schockt weil jesus
vielleicht eine reinkarnation von butter
selber ist und wie würde es dann ab
gehen an dem abend was ist das für eine
gesellschaft die du jetzt aufgebaut hast
sehr divers glaube ich ich glaube es
wäre sehr spannend weil alle irgendwie
aus dem kreativbereich kommen also film
oder literatur und ich glaube es könnte
amüsant werden ja ich glaube jeder würde
was lernen und warum karl marx was
fasziniert dich beim karl marx einfach
die ideen das ist einfach wirklich so
stark von seiner idee überzeugt war
obwohl er trotzdem aus bürgerlichen
behältnissen war also gar nicht von von
also gar nicht in diese idee reinpasse
die ja verfasst hat mit friedrich engels
darum finde ich es ganz interessant und
albert einstellen
ich finde es interessant einfach mit
einem menschen zu sprechen der so schlau
und intelligent ist
einfach mal zu versuchen zu verstehen
wie er denkt erzähl mir von der ersten
person wer war das noch mal
erster preis ist eine schriftstellerin
sie ist psychotherapeut und
paartherapeuten glaube ich auch wo kommt
sie her sie kommt
sie ist geflüchtet
ihre eltern sind holocaust überlebende
und ich glaube sie kommen aus belgien
sie ist weltbekannt und der architekt
hat der berühmte gebäude bürogebäude
entworfen oder rohöl wohne ja der ist
einer der begründer des bauhaus und
nachdem es in berlin die gropiusstadt
benannt dieses große wohnviertel im
süden und wie schaffst du wie schaffst
du es glücklichsten bleiben
ich würde sagen die kleinen dinge
wertschätzen und sich auch nicht so
runterziehen zu lassen wenn mal was
schief läuft also sachen nicht zu viel
gewicht zu geben und sich dann ewig über
irgendwas aufzuregen also und aber mit
diesem ich weil ich kenne den menschen
nicht aber ich muss mir da mit nicht die
betonwüsten vorstellen die ja so ein
bisschen also die gropiusstadt im sinn
von berlin in neukölln die es im
hochhausviertel wo die häuser ganz eng
beisammen sind
das ist so ein bisschen trägt so ein
bisschen zu unrecht seinen namen
eigentlich
er hat sich mir gedanken darüber gemacht
wie man viel wohnraum für leute schaffen
kann nachdem er in deutschland die
städte für nach dem krieg zerstört waren
und die leute irgendwie zu acht im
hinter dritten hinterhof gewohnt haben
mit klo offenen flur und mit mit
kohleöfen und er hat sich viele gedanken
gemacht wie man ja die städte so
gestalten kann dass man viel wohnraum
hat und er hatte das eigentlich vor dass
das alles ein bisschen luftiger ist in
der gruppe statt und mehr grün und die
häuser nicht ganz so hoch aber die die
ideen waren gut auch wenn es in der
umsetzung nicht immer
so toll war jetzt seid ihr dran wir
wollen von euch wissen wen würdet ihr zu
eurem abendessen einladen
schreibt uns einen kommentar hier unten
auf deutsch und schreibt auch warum
würdet ihr diese personen einnahmen und
lernt natürlich weiter deutsch hier in
den kommentaren und als mitglied von the
german dort erhaltet ihr nämlich
vokabeln ein transkript und interaktive
übungen zu diesem video
hier geht es direkt zu betteln und hier
kommt die straßenbahn
liebe leute
[Musik]